Du Herbert, ja schau mal, der Buhr da am Arm hat. Das weiß ich auch nicht. Du sag mal Herbert, wo kommst du denn zu er eigentlich? Du hast gesagt, aus Regensburg, du klingst so anders. Nein, ich komme nicht aus Regensburg. Wow, herzlich willkommen zu einer Ausgabe von das podcast ufo dem ersten interaktiven
krimi podcast den ihr hört mit kommissar stefan an der knarre der einzige kommissar der erst
mal die knarre zieht bevor er fingerabdrücke nimmt und graf Wilhelm von Schwarz, der gemeine Fiesling, der es war.
Richtig, wir befinden uns in einem Herrenhaus, eine grosse Blutlache auf dem Teppich. Oder Frauenhaus, Freudenhaus. So, und ein grosser Löwenpelz, auf dem sich eine grosse Blutlache entfaltet. Folgende Indizien hast du gefunden.
Feuerlöscher?
Ein Konzertflügel, zwei Feuerlöscher und ein Käfig voller Streifenhörnchen. Was machst du? Ähm, ich würfel. Okay. Was würfel ich? Würfel sie drei. Okay, ähm, gut, dann kann ich in den Salon gehen. Ja, du gehst in den Salon. Qualm, Zigarrenqualm steigt dir sofort in die Nase, ein grosser Kronleuchter erleuchtet den gesamten Raum, keine Fenster, dafür sehr viele bequeme Ledersessel. Was machst du? Ich ruhe mir mal kurz die Augen aus, weil das ist ja auch anstrengend, so ein Nachdenkfall. Aber deswegen lede ich mich in den Ledersessel zurück und ruhe mal die Augen aus. Okay, du schläfst ein und fängst an zu träumen. Okay. Du bist in einem Wald, du schaust nach oben, in den Baumkronen, überall auf den Ästen sitzen Streifenhörnchen. Alle Streifenhörnchen mit verschiedensten Waffen. Ich habe das Gefühl, das Spiel will unbedingt, dass ich diesen Streifenhörnchen nachgehe. Du siehst ein Streifenhörnchen mit Messer, eines mit einer Pistole, eines hat einen Morgenstern. Und plötzlich schaust du nach oben und alle Streifenhörnchen von oben gleiten auf dich herunter, um dich auf unterschiedlichste Art zu malträtieren. Der eine schüttet dir Gift ins Gesicht, der andere erdeucht dich, der andere erschiesst dich, alle prasseln auf dich hernieder. Du wachst plötzlich auf, du merkst, es ist mitten in der Nacht, du hast den ganzen Tag verschlafen. Was machst du? Ich würde zurückgehen, um zu gucken, ob da noch die Leiche liegt und die Blutlache auf dem Terbiet. Du gehst zurück, die Leiche liegt immer noch auf dem Löwenpelz. Das heißt, ich als Ermittler bin angekommen, habe die Leiche gesehen, habe gewürfelt, eine Drei, als Spieler keine Rolle mehr gespielt, musste man nicht mehr machen eigentlich. Dann habe ich mich in so einen Sessel gesetzt im anderen Raum und habe bis danach geschlafen. Ja, ja. Das ist nur, dass wir uns sicher sind, dass das bislang die Geschichte ist. Genau, wir sind jetzt im Tatort, du siehst die Leiche, du siehst den blutverschmierten Löwenpelz, du siehst die beiden Feuerlöscher und du siehst den Käfig mit Streifenhörnchen, die mittlerweile schlafen. Ich gehe zum Käfig mit den Streifenhörnchen, um zu gucken, was das damit auf sich und untersuche den Käfig. Es sind sieben Streifenhörnchen, die dort auf verschiedenen Ebenen liegen. Du siehst unten im Heu liegen drei, dann gibt es die erste Kletterstufe, da liegen nochmal zwei und dann gibt es ganz oben nochmal eine höchste Kletterstufe, da liegen nochmal zwei. Alle schlafen. Drei, zwei, zwei. Eine klassische Drei, zwei, zwei Aufstellung, ja. Was tust du? Ich habe das Gefühl, du wolltest eigentlich drei, zwei, eins machen, aber dann ist dir eingefallen, du hast sieben gesagt. Ich will sie nicht wecken, deswegen gehe ich leise vor und untersuche, ob es im Käfig irgendwelche Besonderheiten gibt. Können die da raus oder rein? Nein, der Käfig ist zu, es gibt eine Tür, aber die ist abgeschlossen. Und ansonsten ist der Käfig ziemlich hoch. Also du kannst dir vorstellen, dass die da hoch und runter springen können, da hochklettern.
Es gibt auch so einen grossen Ast, der da reingebaut ist, an den man hochklettern kann.
Ansonsten fällt jetzt erstmal nichts auf. Du kennst dich jetzt aber auch nicht so gut mit Streifenhörnchen aus.
Ja, ich habe Tierkunde drei. Dann würfel gerne mal. Eine vier. Gut, also du merkst sofort, dass eines der Streifenhörnchen ganz ungewöhnlich schläft, denn es schläft auf dem Rücken. Alle anderen Streifenhörnchen schlafen auf dem Bauch. Die gesundeste, auch für Streifenhörnchen, die gesundeste Schlaflage. Ein Streifenhörnchen liegt auf dem Rücken und du merkst, es atmet nicht. Okay. Anscheinend gab es noch einen zweiten Mord an diesem Abend. Ich würde das tote Streifenhörnchen versuchen, da herauszuholen. Okay, also du machst den Käfig auf. Ja, aber ich will die nicht wecken. Ich mach es vorsichtig auf. Gut, dann würf mir mal auf Fingerfertigkeit. Okay, hab ich sehr schlecht, ne? Ich bin der intellektuelle, clumsy Charakter. Okay, wow, aber eine Sechs gewürfelt. Also, du schaffst es, du machst den Käfig auf, ganz vorsichtig, du hast sechsfaches Schnarchen. Ja. Du nimmst das tote Streifenhörnchen heraus. Was, in welcher Ebene war das? Auf der mittleren Ebene.
Ja, ich untersuche es auf mögliche Todesursachen. Dir fällt auf, warum es auf dem Rücken geschlafen hat, denn es hat eine Platzwunder am Hinterkopf. Also von einem stumpfen Gegenstand. Genau. Okay, das heisst, wir müssen jetzt zwei Tatwaffen suchen, zum einen die Menschengrossen, und dann auf Streifenhörnchengrösse suche ich jetzt den kleinen Kronleuchter. Aber es ist ein stumpfer Gegenstand gewesen, nehme ich an. Also du bist jetzt kein Experte, was Mord angeht, aber du vermutest, also es ist keine Schnittwunde oder irgendwie sowas in Richtung, sondern es sieht wirklich wie eine Platzwunde. Okay, ich gehe zu Leiche, zu Menschenleichen, die da liegt auf dem Tigerfell und untersuche, was das für eine Wunde ist. Du schaust dir die an, du siehst einen älteren Herrn gekleidet, einen Langsamtbademantel. Du weißt nicht, wie er heisst. Du hast nie gefragt, wie er heisst. Namensschild, ich suche nach Namensschildern. Er trägt kein Namensschild. Ich suche so gründlich nach einem Namensschild. Nein, du merkst, er trägt nur einen Bademantel, sonst nichts. Einen Samtbademantel, darunter nichts mehr. Mit Initialien drauf oder so? Nein, keine Initialien drauf, nichts. Du merkst aber, der Bademantel hat eine Tasche an der linken Seite und da ist eine Zigarre drin. Okay. Du drehst die Leiche auf die andere Seite und merkst am Hinterkopf eine Platzwunde. Die gleiche Wunde wie beim Streifenhörnchen? Eine sehr ähnliche Wunde wie bei einem Streifenhörnchen. Ich lege das Streifenhörnchen genau daneben auf dem Bauch und gucke mir die beiden Wunden an. In dem Moment, in dem du die Streifenhörnchen neben die Leiche legst, hörst du ein Und da, wo vorher an der Feuerstelle ein prasselndes Feuer den Raum erleuchtet hat, hat sich plötzlich eine Tür aufgetan, die hinter dem Feuer aufgegangen ist. Durch den, habe ich einen Mechanismus ausgelöst? Du scheinst irgendeinen Mechanismus ausgelöst zu haben. Das frage ich mich immer, wie das funktioniert, aber okay, ich schätze, das funktioniert. Gut, dann, ich fahre erschrocken herum, denke mir, ich hätte eigentlich schon ganz früh Kollegen rufen sollten, weil es ist ja, langsam wächst mir das alles ein bisschen über mich hinaus, aber ich untersuche das, weil ich will jetzt herausfinden, wer die beiden umgebracht hat. Also du gehst zur Feuerstelle, wo immer noch ein Feuer prasselt, aber hinter dem Feuer siehst du eine Tür, also eine Kammer, die sich aufgetan hat. Okay, ich nehme einen Feuerlöscher und mache den, dann mache damit, ich benutze Feuerlöscher mit Feuer. Sehr gut. Du drückst auf den Feuerlöscher, es macht ein und das Feuer ist sofort aus, alles ist komplett mit weissem Schaum voll gesprüht. Die Streifhörnchen sind wach, hellwach. Du hast ein sechsfaches, die Streifhörnchen fangen quiekend an, in ihrem Käfig auf und ab zu springen. Ja, ich nehme den, ich ziehe dem alten Mann den Bademantel aus und ich bin ganz aufgeregt und hänge das über den Käfig, damit die schlafen. Ah, okay, nach einer kurzen Zeit hörst du sogar, dass das Quieken aufhört. Okay. Gut, ich gehe über das erloschende Feuer durch die Tür hinten durch. Ja, du gehst durch die Feuerstelle hinten durch und du merkst, es führt eine Treppe nach unten. Ja, ich gehe hier hinab. Du gehst die Treppe hinab. Ich hätte vielleicht einen, so einen Zweig oder so einen Holzscharten überlassen müssen, die brennt. Aber ich gehe hier hinab. Habe ich ein Handy dabei oder so, ein iPhone? Nein. Wie? Hast du im Auto gelassen. Habe ich im Auto gelassen? Gut, soll ich hier noch mal hingehen, soll ich noch mal rausgehen? Nee, komm. Das musst du selber entscheiden, wie... Ich suche nach Lichtschaltern oder Ähnlichem. Okay, also du gehst die Treppe runter, du tastest die Wände ab, aber du findest keine Lichtschalter. Das sind ganz glatte Wände, die in diesen Stein hineingehauen sein müssen.
Nee, ich gehe weiter.
Du gehst weiter, du kommst unten an eine auffällig modern wirkende Tür, wie so eine komplett verglaste Tür mit so Edelstahlrahmen, die aber zu ist.
Okay, die ist zu, ich rüttel dran.
Ja, du findest nicht wirklich Halt, es ist eine Glasscheibe, du findest nicht wirklich Halt, aber plötzlich geht über der Tür ein grünes Licht an. Okay. Guten Abend, Herr Schwarz. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Zugriff bitte. Du hörst ein Zzzz und die Tür öffnet sich. Okay, ich gehe rein. Du gehst rein und plötzlich wird eine grosse Lagerhalle erleuchtet mit grellen Neonlichtern.
Und du siehst überall an den Wänden verschiedene Anzüge.
Du siehst einen blauen Anzug mit einem Schnorchel dran, einen roten Anzug mit so einer Feuerflamme vorne drauf,
ganz viele verschiedene Anzüge, die in Glasröhren die komplette Lagerhalle ausfüllen. Okay. Erkenne ich die Anzüge, kennt man das? Du erkennst keinen der Anzüge. Also es sieht so ein bisschen wie Superhelden-Anzüge aus, aber dir kommt jetzt keiner wirklich bekannt vor. Entscheint bin ich in einer Art Headquarter für Superhelden. Was finde ich noch in dem Raum neben den Anzügen? Was finde ich in der Mitte? Du schaust dich um und du findest auf grossen Tischen ganz viele verschiedene Waffen. Du findest Wurfsterne, Harpunen, so ein Greifhaken, verschiedenste Gefährte, du findest so ein Unterwasserpropellergerät, ein Motorrad, eine Tischtennisplatte, du findest ein grosses Auto, ein Boot. Ja, ich stecke mir eine Waffe ein, so Dinge, die man gut gebrauchen kann, die ich auch benutzen kann. Ja, du hast so eine pistolengrosse Harpunenschießwaffe, steckst du dir ein. Stecke ich mir ein, okay, alles klar. Und dann schaue ich mich um, kann ich einen der Anzüge anziehen? Du gehst zu einem dieser grossen Glastuben hin. Sind die denn menschengross oder streifenhörnchengross? Nee, die sind menschengross. Ich dachte gerade, wir haben so ein Chip and Chap Szenario, wo halt die Streifen, die nicht von oben, vielleicht superhelden sind. Nee, du siehst, die sind menschengross. Okay, gut, kann ich einen anziehen? Du gehst vor so eine Glasröhre und auch über dieser Glasröhre geht so ein grünes Licht an. Weil ich jetzt die Japuna eingesteckt habe, würde ich zum blauen Schnorchel-Outfit gehen. Okay, über dem Outfit geht ein grünes Licht an. Guten Abend, Herr Schwarz. Der blaue Anzug, dann soll's dann sein, danke. Die Röhre öffnet sich in zwei Teile und du kannst auf den Anzug zugreifen. Okay, ich hab auch versucht, genau wie er zu klingen. Dieser Mann, den ich erst tot aufgefunden habe. Okay, ich ziehe mir diesen Anzug an, mit den grossen Flossen, der neoprenartige Anzug, mit dem Schnorchelding und diesen Taucherbrillen. Er ist sehr eng, er ist sehr eng geschnitten, er ist sogar ein bisschen dir zu eng, also das Gummi schneidet ein bisschen in deine Gelenke hinein, es fällt dir schwer, dich da rein zu zwängen. Und es ist sehr, sagen wir mal, revealing. Ja, allerdings, auf jeden Fall. Also, es gibt auch einen grossen Spiegel in dem Raum, du schaust ihn an und du fühlst dich nicht ganz wohl in deinem Körper, weil gerade hintenrum, also es schneidet dann durchaus in alle Ecken und Kanten hinein. Minus zwei Charme. Richtig. Okay, jetzt wo ich den Anzug an habe und diese Harpoonwaffe würde ich mich, ja, finde ich in den Unterlagen irgendwie was, wo ich da gerade bin. Ja, du schaust die Unterlagen durch und du findest so eine Art Blaupause, so eine Art Bauplan für einen weiteren Glaskanister und du siehst nur so skizzen-schemenhaft in diesem Glaskanister ein menschengrosses Streifenhörnchen eingezeichnet.
Du findest diesen Behälter aber nirgendwo in dem Raum.
Oh mein Gott.
Okay, menschengrosses Streifenhörnchen heisst aber, die sind die Arme, weil der Anzug ist ja schon, passt mir ja schon als Menschen.
Der Anzug ist definitiv für Menschen gedacht.
Nee, nicht für menschengrosse Streifenhörnchen.
Nein, das nicht. Also zum Beispiel, es gibt keine Möglichkeit, den Schwanz unterzubringen. Gibt es eine andere Tür? Es gibt auf der Stirnseite des Raumes noch eine Tür. Egal, ob sie offen ist oder nicht, ich schiesse mit der Harpunenwaffe auf das Schloss. Okay, du schiesst auf das Schloss, die Tür ist bereits offen, es macht ein Krrk und ein Schliessgeräusch, es verändert sich aber nichts, da die Tür bereits offen steht. Okay, okay. Ich gehe durch die Tür. Du gehst durch die Tür und in einem zweiten Raum geht ein grelles Licht an und du siehst einen grossen Glaskanister, randvoll gefüllt mit Wasser und in diesem Wasser schwimmend bewusstlos ein menschengr mir ... hörst. Ich dreh mich um, von wo kommt die Stimme. Du siehst niemanden, von dem die Stimme hätte kommen. Ich frag leise, hallo, wer spricht? Du schaust dich genau um und du siehst, dass das Streifenhörnchen mit seiner linken Pfote zuckt. Das Grosse? Ja. Aber es kam definitiv nicht von ihm. Du weisst es nicht, du hast es nicht gesehen. Ich krieg's mit der Panik zu tun. Gibt's irgendwo einen Knopf, dass man den wieder bewusstlos machen kann? Es gibt ganz viele Knöpfe in diesem Raum. Verschiedenste Knöpfe beschriftet mit dingen die du nicht verstehst xt 500 300 ganz verschiedene knöpfe xt 300 hier we go du haust auf den knopf und plötzlich sinkt der wasserspiegel in dem wasser wasser ich habe 500 du haust auf 500 das wasser sinkt noch schnell ach du scheiße wird abgepumpt 100 auf 100 100 es es sinkt langsam. Das ist die Schwindigkeit des Abflusses.
Dafür gibt's...
Digga, dieser Professor hat viel zu viel Zeit gehabt, wenn er das einrichten konnte. Okay, 50. 50, es sinkt sehr langsam. Trotzdem im Raum ein... Ja, ich sag, okay, wer hat gerufen, wer hat gerufen, wer hat gerufen!
Das Wasser senkt sich langsam und mit dem Wasserstand sinkt auch der Streifenhörnchenkörper auf dem Boden zusammen.
Ein elendes Häufchen von einem nassen Fellknäuel liegt auf dem Boden. Stinkt, glaube ich, ein bisschen, so ein nasses Fell. Die linke Pfote zuckt immer noch so ein bisschen. Okay, ich will diesem etwas helfen. Ich weiss nicht, was es ist. Es ist halb Mensch, halb Streifenhörnchen. Ich denke mir, auch dieses Kreatur hat es verdient zu leben. Und ich gehe hin und mache ...
Du gehst an den grossen Glaskanister dran. Auch über dem Glaskanister ist ein grünes Licht, das sagt, guten Abend, Herr Schwarz, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was glauben Sie denn, was Sie für mich tun können? Öffnen Sie den Tank. Der Tank öffnet sich in zwei Teile.
Wofür ist diese Sicherheit?
Noch ein bisschen Wasser läuft die entgegen und du siehst vor dir dieses komplett triefen, klatschnasse Wesen. Okay, ich ziehe es an den Armen raus. Du ziehst es auf den Rücken und es fällt auf den Rücken, alle Gliedmassen fallen davon ab, du siehst den grossen weissen Bauch und in dem Moment scheint es dich anzuschauen und die Augen leicht zu öffnen. Und ich sage, hey, hey, hey, alles gut? Töte mich, töte mich! Nein, nein, alles gut, alles gut, beruhig dich, beruhig dich, du bist jetzt wach. Mich und die linke Kralle packt deine Hand. Okay. Ich versuche mich zu lösen und das Wesen zu beruhigen. Ja, du kannst dich noch davon lösen und du stehst vor dem Wesen,
das langsam die Augen öffnet und fieberhaft herumguckt. Was ist hier passiert? Erzähl mir,
was hier passiert ist. Der Graf, ich konnte nicht mehr, ich habe alles gesehen. Was denn,
was hast du gesehen? Ich habe alles gesehen. Was? Von was hast du gesehen? Ich hab alles gesehen.
Was?
Von hier unten, wie es passiert ist. Ich hab das Gefühl, es stirbt jetzt genau, wenn es den Täter sagt. Wie jeden Abend setzte sich der Graf vor seine Feuerstelle und hörte Beethovens siebte Sinfonie, doch kurz vorm Finale kam plötzlich eine Gestalt hinter ihm und schwang einen Feuerlöscher und ich weiss noch genau, wer es war, es war ... Nein, nein, bleib bei mir, bleib bei mir, jetzt rück du es mal ... Und plötzlich erbricht dieses Wesen eine schleimige, gelehrtartige Masse vor deine Füsse und du findest darin einen Schlüssel. Einen Schlüssel? Okay, ich nehme den Schlüssel an mich. Okay. Finde ich noch was anderes im galertartigen Mageninhalt? Nein. Okay, ich nehme den Schlüssel und wie sieht der aus? Ist es ein moderner Schlüssel oder ist es eher ein altmodischer Schlüssel? Es ist ein moderner Schlüssel, also wirklich so ein moderner Schlüssel mit vielen Zacken. Also passt eher in diesen Bereich dieses Hauses als jetzt die alten Sachen um. Ja, ja. Gibt es noch eine andere Tür, die ich sehen kann? Du siehst drei Türen, eine silberne, eine goldene und eine schwarze. Welche Farbe ist der Schlüssel? Der Schlüssel ist silber. Ja, ich versuche es mit der silbernen Tür. Du steckst den silbernen Schlüssel in die silberne Tür, du drehst den Schlüssel und es macht klack und die Tür geht auf. Kannst du die Tür öffnen. Ja, ich nehme den Schlüssel nochmal raus und versuche die goldene Tür. Du steckst den silbernen Schlüssel in die goldene Tür und der Schlüssel bleibt klemm und du kriegst den nicht mehr raus. Ach so, Schande, okay, gut, ich gehe durch die silberne Tür. Du gehst durch die silberne Tür und stehst plötzlich im Freien. Ah pfff! Du stehst an einer Klippe, unter dir ein brandendes Meer, die Wellen schlagen gegen die Felsen. Kann ich mich erinnern, wie ich in dieses Haus gekommen bin? Du erinnerst, versuchst dich zu erinnern, und du kannst dich nicht erinnern, wie du reingekommen bist. Das hab ich mir nicht gedacht. Okay, ich gehe von der Klippe weg, will nicht runterfallen, gehe durch die Tür hinter mir und schliess die Tür. Okay, schliess die Tür wieder. Okay, ich durchsuche irgendwie das Labor, was es da noch gibt, ist nicht so gross wahrscheinlich wie das erste, nach einem schwarzen Schlüssel.
Ja, du durchsuchst das Labor und du findest Unterlagen, wo du einige Bilder und Daten findest zu diesem Streifenhörnchenwesen.
Also die Entwicklung so, du siehst so ein Embryo, das dann immer grösser wird und du blätterst so ein bisschen durch die Dokumente und du findest plötzlich ein Foto von dir. Ein Kinderfoto? Nein, ein relativ aktuelles Foto, wie du vor zwei Monaten bei McDrive stehst und mit dem McDonnell-Mitarbeiter streitet. Streitet es?
Ich weiß noch genau, was da passiert ist.
Ich habe fünf Chicken Nuggets nur bekommen und das ist nicht zum ersten Mal passiert bei diesem konkreten McDonalds.
Und da bin ich eigentlich immer gern, aber das mit den Chicken Nuggets,
das war mir einfach aufgeregt.
Du blätterst weiter und du findest ein perfekt präzises Protokoll dieses Gesprächs zwischen dir und dem McDonalds-Mitarbeiter. Wort für Wort aufgeschrieben. Jedes Jahr ist die Zeit der Zeit, die die Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Streiten. Jeder Faustschlag aufs Armaturenbrett ist dort ganz penibel mit Timecode niedergeschrieben. Okay, ich blätter weiter. Wie weit geht das zurück, wie weit werde ich schon beobachtet? Es geht Wochen und Wochen und Wochen. Alles, was ich gesagt habe. Alles, was du jemals gesagt hast, während du in deinem Auto sitzt. Nur während ich in meinem Auto sitze. Du siehst immer nur Dinge, die du getan hast, während du im Auto bist. Ganz viele Fotos bei dir im Auto, einige Blitzerfotos auch, einige Fotos, wo du im Stau stehst, wo du mit der flachen Hand aufs Armaturenbrett haust, verschiedenste Situationen. Wie ich mitsinge auch? Auch wie du mitsingst, ja, der komplette Text, auch mit unverständliches Gemurmel, unverständlich Manchmal weiss man den Text nicht, manchmal weiss man es nicht. Okay, denn ich will gerne zu meinem Auto gehen, ich will meinem Auto und, äh, untersuchen, wo ich da bestattet wurde und durch was. Okay, also du verlässt den Raum mit dem Streifenhärchen, du gehst wieder in das ursprüngliche Labor und, ähm, du gehst wieder in den Raum mit dem Lagerfeuer. Genau, Salon. Du versuchst wieder zurückzugehen, doch du merkst, die Tür lässt sich nicht öffnen. Okay, ich rüttel dran. Du rüttelst dran. Ich versuch's nochmal mit der Harpune dagegen zu schiessen. Du schiessst mit der Harpune dagegen, doch du kommst nicht durch diese Tür durch. Okay, gut, dann liegt die Antwort wahrscheinlich unten im Labor. Ich gehe jetzt zurück ins Labor. Du gehst zurück ins Labor, ins erste Labor, ins grosse Labor. Genau, suche hier nach Schütteln. Du hast immer noch den Schnorchelanzug an, ne? Ich gehe durch silberne Tür und spring von der Klippe.
Du, ichppe mutig ins Wasser. Du springst von der Klippe, du stürzt herunter, die Felsen rauschen an dir vorbei, das Meer kommt immer näher und in der Sekunde, in der du auf dem Wasser aufschlägst, wachst du auf und du sitzt im Sessel im Nebenraum des Herrenhauses. Ich hasse Pin and Paper auch ein bisschen. Ende. Das war unser erster aktives... Und du hörst aus dem Nebenraum Beethovens siebte Sinfonie. Du gehst langsam zur Tür, öffnest sie und siehst den Herrn Grafen, wie er lebendig in seinem Sessel sitzt. Und er schaut dich langsam an und sagt, na da bist du ja endlich, das Abendessen ist schon angerichtet. er weist auf eine komplett gedeckte Tafel und er weist auf einen Sitzplatz, du setzt dich hin und auf dem Teller vor dir liegt das fehlende Chicken McNugget.
Sie hörten, das Herrenhaus, vorgetragen von Florentin Will, alle anderen Rollen, Stefan Tietze, Musik, Beethoven, eine Produktion von Worst Bird Productions, Kreh. Ja, das war das erste kleine Abenteuer, das werden wir jetzt jede Woche fortführen. Die Geschichten von Kommissar Thies sind noch nicht zu Ende. Ja, vielen Dank an Josephine, die uns mit ihrem Intro inspiriert hat zu diesem kleinen Krimi. Danke. Ja, Josephine, vielen Dank. Und sie dreht sich so, sie steht auf und dreht sich zu einer anderen Hörerin und Hörerin und sagt so, sorry.
An dieser Stelle sorry, ich will es, ich habe das jetzt raus gelernt und ich werde es auch nicht wiederholen. Und demnächst schicke ich einfach ein ganz normales, spaciges Intro ein. Und die komplette Podcast-UFO-Community nickt verständlich und sagt, den Fehler haben wir alle schon gemacht. Den Fehler, ein irreführendes Intro zu machen. Was die beiden in komische Welten bringt. Diesen Fehler haben wir wirklich alle schon gemacht. Wahnsinn. Ja, vielen, vielen Dank für das tolle Intro. Danke, Josephine. Und ich habe einen Fleck auf dem T-Shirt. Ich wollte ihn nur einordnen.
Wenn du das jetzt ansprichst, dass du ein Flecken, wenn du immer Flecken auf dem T-Shirt hast, weil du reisst jetzt was ein, das ist ein Präzedenzfall.
Ach so.
Weil du hast vorher, du hast schon auch Flecken auf dem T-Shirt. Du meinst, dass alle anderen kanonischen Flecken auf T-Shirts bis dahin dann unerklärt sind.
Ich finde, ab jetzt ist es komisch, wenn du einmal nicht ansprichst, dann denkt man sich, warum verheimlichst du uns diesen Flecken?
Ja.
Und weil ab jetzt, du reisst, das ist ja jetzt ein Präzedenzfall, du reisst jetzt damit ein.
Ich glaube, es ist hilfreich, wenn man sagt, was der Fleck ist. Also wenn du jemandem gegenüber sitzt und der hat so einen wirklich so einen rotzgelben Fleck auf dem T-Shirt, so den ganzen Abend. Ja. Und den ganzen Abend denkst du dir, also wenn du niest, ich meine, geht das so, also ich meine, was ist, also kommt es von innen, kommt es von außen, was ist los? Ja. Als wenn du einfach sagst, ah ja, Vanillepudding, der Mixer, der Quirl, wenn es quirlt, wenn es quirlt. Und ich habe ja so einen Mixer, wo oben der Deckel drauf ist, wo so ein kleines Loch drin ist, wo man dann noch gefrorene Kirschen reintun kann. Der Erbauer dieses ... Ein gefrorenes Kirschen, grosses Loch? Ja. Okay. Wo man aber noch eine gefrorene Kirsche, wenn man sie vergessen hat. Okay. Mit der Waschmaschine wäscht und dann merkst du, die Socken. Deswegen hat die Waschmaschine ja oben noch so ein kleines Loch, wo du die Socken reinwerfen kannst. Ja. Und die Kirsche und dann der Erbauer dachte wahrscheinlich, Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der Mixer-Inhalt durch dieses eine Loch oben rausspritzt, ist verschwindend gering, aber heute ist es passiert und ist mir dann direkt aufs T-Shirt gesprungen. Ach nein. Ich mache mir jeden Morgen Vanillepudding und werfe dann noch eine gefrorene Kirsche rein und ja, da ist es dann passiert. Es ist die Frage, wie detailliert muss diese Geschichte sein, dass man es nicht mehr glaubt ja das stimmt weil wer lügt er findet details du machst du fügst viele details hinzu wenn du lügst aber die wahrheit spricht hat ja einfach details aber die lässt man weg weil die sind egal weil die sind trivial des alltags banales banales blablabla ja ja man würde weglassenert. Hm, angefrotzt. Das bringt mich jetzt dazu, dass ich da, du lügst. Das ist nicht passiert. Ich habe auch reich gesagt, was der Fleck ist. Nee, genau, sag mal, was der Fleck ist. Ist eine Fliege, die ich erschlagen habe. Auf deinem Bauch? Auf meinem Bauch, ja. Auf meinem Bauch. Ich habe laut gelacht. Er hat mir dabei auf den Bauch geschlagen.
Auf den Bauch geschlagen und wir schauen uns das in der Zeitlupe an. Die Fliege kam genau in dem und genau in dem. Habe ich genau die Fliege erwischt und dann war das Lachen aber vorbei. Aber woher kommt das, weil das mache ich gar nicht mehr. Ich kenne auch niemanden, der das macht. Ich haue aufs Bein manchmal. Man schlägt aufs Bein, man reibt sich den Bauch, man hält sich die Seiten. Wir gehen das jetzt wirklich nochmal duolingomässig durch. Man schlägt sich nicht auf den Bauch. Nein, man hält sich den Mund zu. Aber wenn was sehr lecker ist, dann haut man sich auf den Bauch. Nee, dann klopft man sich so. Gut gemacht, Bauch. Also lachend kenne ich Leute, ich klatsche auch manchmal, die auch unangenehm. Ehrlich gesagt, mag ich nicht diese Eigenschaft an mir. Dann haue ich mir manchmal aufs Bein lachend, richtig, wenn ich schallend lachend. Schenkel klopfen, ja. Wie dieses Wetten-Das-Publikum, was immer dann so mit den Beinen trommelt.
Stirbt das eigentlich aus? Ist euch nichts peinlich, denke ich dann immer.
Ist euch da draußen wirklich gar nichts peinlich?
So Leute, die dann so, ich habe mich noch nie über irgendwas im Leben so sehr gefreut, dass ich mit beiden Beinen auf dem Boden stampeln muss.
Vor allem jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, also ich bin jetzt keine Sportskanone, aber ich finde das vergleichsweise anstrengend.
Ich meine, du musst ja dein, also allein auf dem Stuhl zu sitzen und dann deine Füsse vom Boden zu heben und dann aber, ja, so schnell es geht zu trampeln, ist gar nicht so leicht.
Nee, Oberschenkeltraining. Es ist nicht trivial. Das wäre gar nicht schlecht. Aber ich glaube, das stirbt aus, oder? Also so bei modernen Shows, jetzt nehmen wir mal so eine moderne Show, Neo Ragazzi oder sowas, was die jungen Kids anschauen, da wird das, glaube ich, nicht mehr so praktiziert mit dem Getrampel, glaube ich. Wo kommt das denn her?
Also, du hast ja… Also, Musikshows, so Viva und sowas, wo das häufig geht.
Aber du hast ja Klatschen so, also was es ja gibt zum Beispiel ist im Unikontext so das Klopfen, wo man ja wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Abhandlung schreiben könnte, warum das so ist.
Wann klopft man, wann klatscht man?
Wann klopft man, wann klatscht man? Bei uns gab es in der Schule eine Lehrerin und dann war zum Beispiel ein Referat und die ganze Referat ist vorbei, die Klasse klatscht und die Lehrerin hat immer geklopft. Weil sie noch in ihrem, ich komme aus der Uni, ich bin jetzt zwar unter euch, Proleten, aber ich bin immer noch von der Uni und klopfe noch. Und ich fand das immer, ich fand es richtig cool, ich fand es heiß, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ich wollte, dass du das cool findest.
Ja, ich weiß, weil ich habe das davor noch nie erlebt, weil für sie geht ja die Zeit, für Lehrer geht die Zeit ja umgedreht. Die sind ja erst an der Uni, dann an der Schule. Sie sind Countdown zum Tod.
Dann Kindergarten, dann Kindheit. Und für den normalen Menschen geht es andersrum, erst Schule, dann Uni. Das heißt, sie ist eine Zeitreisende, die Dinge aus der Zukunft mitbringt, die man selber noch gar nicht kennt, das Klopfen. Super. Und man versteht das überhaupt nicht. Und erst in der Uni merkt man, ach jetzt, jetzt ergibt alles Sinn. Ich überlege auch, bei uns war es so in der Oberstube für wahrscheinlich das schon an mit dem Klopfen. Ja? Ja, also es gab diese, die klatschende Kindheit, die auch mal was spaß macht aber irgendwann ist das zu trivial es ist so es wirkt zu politarisch es geht ja vom also wenn man sich jetzt so eine betende hand vorstellt kinder klatschen ja wie beschreibt man das ja hand auf hand direkt aufeinander ja und je älter du wirst desto grösser wird der abstand der Winkel wird grösser, bis irgendwann du Konzertpublikum bist und dann auch verschiebt sich's nach unten, so dass die Oberseite der Handfläche die Unterseite der Handfläche trifft und dann geht's über zu klopfen. Also damit hätte niemand gerechnet.
Die Hände gehen auseinander. Die Hände gehen wirklich in einer Wischgeste auseinander.
Man müsste das mal im Zeitraffer sehen, also die Entwicklung eines Menschen wirklich im Klatschprozess.
Und dann stampfen.
Da war es auch Kinder, glaube ich.
Also Kinder klatschen, stampfen, dann werden die Beine immer ruhiger, während die Hände sich auseinander bewegen, zur Faust klopfen und dann nichts mehr.
Und dann aber das Publikum stampft wieder.
Wenig machen. Ich glaube, die machen wenig. Aber ich kann sehr laut klatschen, Achtung. Machen wir die Kopfhörer ab. Wow, okay, das ist laut, das ist laut, das ist das Wagner-Klatschen, das man wirklich aus der letzten Reihe noch gehört hat. Ich kann so laut klatschen. Jetzt tut's weh? Nein. Ne? Ich mag's gern. Geil. Auch mit einer Hand?
Ja, kann ich nur schnipsen. An die Damenwelt da draußen. Ich habe gehört, Frauen finden das, das kann man auch öffnen, diese Frage, aber findet ihr schnipsen sexuell attraktiv? Stefan hat alles durchprobiert. Also wirklich alles. Vom Pfeifen, zum Zungeschnalzen,
zum lauten Mits Stefan hat alles als Balztechnik wirklich mal probiert und es hat nichts funktioniert und jetzt kommt dann, vielleicht ist Schnippen dann tatsächlich der Schlüssel. Nee, weil es kam mal jemand zu mir im Club in einer Tanzsituation und hat gesagt, das Schnipsen ist ... lass das. Und das nimmt einem alles. Feedback on the dance floor. Feedback on the dance floor. I'm infected by the sound. Ja, und das ist wirklich, holy shit, das ist so ein vernichtendes Urteil, weil es sagt aus, ich schnipp so viel, dass es nicht mehr nur als, weiss nicht ich lasse es einstreuen gimmick durchgeht sondern am fein habe ich so oft geschnipst dass es leuten auffällt bis zu dem moment dass sie mir das jetzt sagen musste das heißt aber nicht so den klassischen coolen jazz ich schnipp durchgehend ich dachte ich sehe aus wie army hammer in call me by your name da gibt es diese tanzszene und er tanzt cool und ab und zu die arme so hoch und er schnipp durchgehend, ich bin so cool zur Bewegung. Ich dachte, ich sehe aus wie Armie Hammer in Call Me By Your Name.
Da gibt es diese Tanzszene und er tanzt cool und ab und zu, die Arme so hoch und er schnippst ab und zu, ganz selten, tutil. Also es ist ganz einfach eingestreut, wie eine Olive im Salat, so hier und da mal. Exakt, ganz ähnlich, Pinienkerne drüber, es ist wie Seasoning. Ich stell da nicht so und hab dann da irgendwie wie so einen Jazz-Schnipser, so cool oder so, wie so, weiss ich nicht, bei West Side Story bin ich durch die Gassen gegangen. Nein, das war nur so ein subtiles Mal einflechten Schnipsen, aber wurde outgecallt. Wurde kritisiert, wurde direkt ausgepfiffen. Ich meine, wie lange hat er dir zugeschaut, oder er oder sie dir zugeschaut, bis man den Punkt kam, so hat es eigentlich was. Ja eben! Weil das Verhalten muss sich jetzt in einem gewissen Grad wiederholen, wie wenn jemand im Zug spricht, du gehst ja nicht beim ersten Mal hin, du denkst dir, okay, innerhalb von zehn Minuten sieben Mal auffallen, mehr als einmal pro Minute so und dann guckst du und dann gehst du ran. Jeder hat eine Toleranzgrenze und niemand mag sich in dieser Rolle des Feedbackers, Feedback on the dance floor, niemand mag sich darin, heisst, die Hemmschwelle muss deutlich überschritten worden sein. Also hast du es angepasst, hast du jetzt deinen Schritt reduziert oder auf null? Sofort aufgehört, null. Und ersetzt jetzt durch ein Klatschen oder durch ein Pfeifen mit den Fingern im Mund zu pfeifen oder ein Hilfesuchender Blick. Mit einem Blick, der basically sagt, was macht man mit den Händen, was macht man jetzt eigentlich mit den Händen. Ey, fang damit nicht an. Das grosse Problem ist, was mache ich mit dem Gesicht beim Tanzen, wenn du jetzt auch noch die Hände aufmachst. Du kannst dich irgendwann nicht mehr bewegen. Zu viele Baustellen. Ja, du hast zu viele Baustellen. Was mache ich hier? Ja, das funktioniert nicht mehr, du kannst dich gar nicht mehr bewegen. Aber es ist schwierig, ne? Aber es gibt ja zum Glück heutzutage viel Getanzer, also Instagram, TikTok, sehr viel Tanz, versteht jeder, kannst du international machen, ist irgendwie immer lustig, Trend und so, und da kannst du ja dir was abgucken, kannst du ja mal gucken, was machen die mit den Händen, weil nur auf die Hände achten. Ich hätte gerne auch so ein stabilisiertes Video mit der Hand in der Mitte, das nur die Hand zeigt, einfach beim Tanz, so dass man wirklich Tanz auch Stück für Stück lernt.
Ja, wir haben übrigens tolles Feedback bekommen und eine Hilfestellung an dich, weil wir haben in den letzten Folgen häufiger mal konkav und konvex aufgemacht. Falsch benutzt, falsch benutzt.
Falsch benutzt, schon gesagt, ich kann eigentlich nichts mehr lernen, weil ich weiss nicht mehr, nicht mal mehr, was konkav und konvex heißt.
Ich kriege das nicht zusammen.
Also warum sollte ich überhaupt noch was über die Welt lernen und Dokumentation gucken, weil du hast ja nicht mal das verstanden. Vielleicht ist das jetzt vorbei, denn wir haben einen Merksatz bekommen und über den gilt es zu sprechen. Darüber müssen wir diskutieren, denn es gibt diesen sehr alten, bisschen in die Jahre gekommenen Satz. Ist der Bauch konkav, war das Mädchen brav, ist der Bauch konvex, hatte das Mädchen Sex.
und ich finde das also erstmal wir haben schon lange eselsbrücken untersucht auf
anwendbarkeit weil manchmal ist der spruch zwar cool aber du kannst die
wörter in sich tauschen, weil sich oft nicht die Dinge reimen, die man zusammenbringen muss. Das wird sehr, sehr gut gemacht. Also klassischer Springer am Rand bringt Kummer und Schand, wo sich nichts auf das Wort Springer reint. Oder willst du dich billig besaufen, musst du Oettinger kaufen. Nichts reimt sich hier auf ... Bier auf Wein, das lass sein. Ja genau, du kannst genauso sagen, Wein auf Bier, nee. Das rate ich dir. Wein vor Bier oder so, du kannst ja dann das Wort umdrehen, das ist dann das Problem. Aber hier wunderbar und es zeigt natürlich auch einen gewissen Trend in Eselsbrücken, der mir auffällt, ist natürlich das Schmuddelige. Wohl noch. Wir denken natürlich alle an die Traufsteinhöhle, die Stalaktiten, die hängen. Das ist natürlich eine Schwachstelle des menschlichen Schmuddelkopfes, dass man sich sowas gut merken kann. Was natürlich, dann hat man natürlich diesen Schmutz im Kopf. Auf der anderen Seite haben mich tatsächlich auf Reddit noch einige andere Eselsbrücken gesehen, wo es hieß, ja, Concav da ist kann man Kaffee draus trinken,
also hat eine
Hohlraum, Konkav, Cave, Höhle.
Cave, und jetzt kommt meine Eselsbrücke.
Wenn es drei
Eselsbrücken gibt
für etwas, dann ändert das Wort.
Dann ist der Punkt gekommen,
wo das Wort zu schwierig ist.
Dann sagt krumm und ausgeholt.
Dann sagt krumm und ausgeholt, gib mir Begriffe, die besser funktionieren.
Meine Eselsbrücke ist
drei Eselsbrücken
Vielen Dank. wo das Wort zu schwierig ist, dann sagt krumm und ausgeholt, dann sagt krumm und ausgeholt, gib mir Begriffe, die besser funktionieren. Meine Eselsbrücke ist drei Eselsbrücken gleich Wortänderung. Das würde ich gern machen. Das ist dann einfach, wo man dann auf einmal sagt, das ist zu kompliziert. Warum müssen die Wörter so ähnlich sein? Aber auch, jetzt sagt der Deep Dive Dinosaur, der das gepostet hat, vielen Dank, Deep Dive, schreibt, seither habe ich alles andere mathematisch vergessen, aber das ist hängen geblieben. Und da muss man dann auch sagen, vielleicht nicht schlecht. Ich meine, wenn die alles andere abhanden gekommen ist, kommt man jetzt auch nicht so weit, dass man konkav und konvex noch unterscheidet. Das Problem mit dem konkav und konvex ist ja auch immer die Perspektive. Wenn du sagst, das Mädchen war brav, ist konkav, aus wessen Perspektive? Ich, der dem Mädchen gegenüberstehe. Aber aus Sicht des Mädchens. Weil das, also ein Objekt kann ja nicht konkav oder konvex sein, weil wenn du es umdrehst, dann ist es andersrum, oder? Nee, glaub nicht. Doch, weil der Bauch des Mädchens ist ja nach aussen gewölbt, aber von innen ist es ja, wenn du das Baby bist, dann ist es ja nach innen, also zu dir gewölbt, nicht von dir weg. Doch, von dir weg, als Baby ist es von dir weg. Wenn du im Bauch sitzt, dann ist es doch zu dir gewölbt, nicht von dir weg. Dann bist du weiter weg vom Scheitelpunkt. Ach so meinst du das, ja. Aber wenn du von aussen vor der schwangeren Frau stehst, dann ist es von dir weg. So, das heisst, ob es koncav oder konvex ist, ist ja immer eine Perspektivfrage. Deswegen, wer bin ich in dem Spiel? Bin ich das Mädchen, bin ich das Baby oder bin ich der Betrachter, der vor dem Mädchen steht? Das ist immer das Problem an diesen Sachen. Deswegen hilft das nicht. Stalaktiten sind immer Titen. Die hängen, egal ob, egal, wer betrachtet so. Das ist immer gleich. Das ist, glaube ich, mein Problem mit Konkar von Convex und deswegen lassen diese Begriffe einfach auf die Müllhalte der Geschichte bringen. Das ist mein Problem mit rechts und links. Richtig. Weil es ist relativ, es kommt immer darauf an, wer spricht Bühnenrechts, Bühnen links, dein rechts, mein rechts, das ist alles. Ja, lass uns einfach keine Wörter mehr benutzen. Nein, keine Wörter, nur noch Norden, Osten, Süden, Westen. Klare Gesten. Klare. Ja, lasst zurückdringen. Weniger reden, mehr so und dann muss also wie komme ich zum Bahnhof also sie müssen erst ganz weit und dann aber auch so und dann Vorsicht weil dann Vorsicht vor dem Polizisten. Ja, da hinten sind Polizisten, so viele Polizisten.
Achtung, vor den vier Polizisten.
Die Schi... ja, ist schwierig.
Die Schiessen.
Ja, ja.
Ja, also deswegen, okay, vielen Dank trotzdem an Deep Dive Dinosaur.
Ja, es ist wieder mehr Verwirrung mit drin, aber das gehört nun mal dazu. Es ist schwierig.
Ja, ist es auch. Die Welt ist nicht einfach. Deswegen versuchen wir jede Woche irgendwie ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkel zu bringen. Ist aber tatsächlich, man muss nur sagen, Eselsbrücken sind wirklich das einzige, was übrig bleiben aus der Schule.
So Quintenzirkel, frische Brezen essen, Asse des Gesangs, geh du alter Esel, hol Fische, die Gitarrenseiten, ein alter Dackel ging Honig essen, wirklich ist das einzige was bleibt. Heringe bei uns. Oh, ein Dackel ist Heringe. Alter Dackel ging Heringe essen, glaube ich. Und zwar ist Honig. Und das ist ja auch ganz spannend, ne? Also wie denn so leichte lokale Unterschiede.
Und deswegen hört er das Podcast-Ufo, weil das ist spannend.
Ja.
Nicht? Ist das nicht super spannend?
Was, der redet leicht anders als ich.
Da reden wir jetzt eine halbe Stunde drüber, warum es bei euch Honig war.
Ich finde aber, ich finde das Bild witziger, wenn der Dackel Honig isst.
Heringe ist so, klar, der Dackel isst auch mal Heringe, aber Honig? Wie macht er das? Honig ist süss. Das stimmt, also Eselsbrücken bleiben über und alles, was so Formeln ist, habe ich nicht mehr im Kopf. Nee, Formeln sind schwierig. Könntest du die noch hin, die PQ-Formel? Die Allegadro, Konstante, Mohl, nee, ist alles weg. Alles weg. Du hast auch das bayerische Abitur, ne? Das ist schon noch krasser. Ich habe mir einige Formelsammlungen aber mitgenommen auch so. Da gab es mal so einen Mathe-Tag und da lagen so Formelsammlungen aus, da war so eine Box und da habe ich mir so ein paar mitgenommen. So fünf, also die sind jetzt nicht einfach so normal gebunden. Bis heute habe ich die. Bis heute liegen alle fünf, so Hefte, liegen bei mir im Schrank, nie gebraucht, nie angefasst, aber ich habe sie immer noch da.
Kann sie verkaufen.
Kann sie verkaufen. Wissen ist wertvoll. Wissen ist Macht. Und was ist Macht wert in Euro? Tausend Euro.
Macht ist tausend Euro wert.
Ja, Macht ist tausend Euro wert. Kannst du direkt mitnehmen.
Komm zu mir. Ich lege dir mal raus. Hast du jemals schon was aus diesen zu verschenken Kisten genommen, die draußen rumliegen?
Genommen, noch nicht.
Du hast ja einmal Argo gesehen, glaube ich. Oder du hast Argo vergeben.
Nee, ich habe Argo mehrere Male gesehen und selber einmal rausgelegt mit anderen DVDs und Argo blieb über.
Ja.
Also und dann finde ich auch, es ist ja fast höflicher, dann die Kiste auch leer zu machen.
Ich finde, also wenn du dann irgendwie drei DVDs nimmst und Argo lässt du über, ist unglücklich.
Ja, das ist unglücklich.
Ich finde, dann sollte man Argo auch noch nehmen und dann kann man die Kiste auch noch wegschmeissen.
Weil du bist ja schon also der Bodensatz des Bodensatzes.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, das, was du nicht sehen willst.
So wenn du jetzt irgendwie durch die Strasse läufst und du siehst irgendwie How to Sell Drugs Staffel 1 DVD in so einer Kiste. Unsere berühmte DVD-Baus. Ja gut, als Netflix-Besitzer bist du natürlich davor gefeiert, aber wenn dein Buch Die Schatten in Rom, dein Erstlingswerk, wenn das da liegt, ungelesen, offensichtlich ungelesen, liegt es da, Stefan Tietze, Die Schatten in Rom, liegt da, das ist schon ein Schlag ins Herz. Auch noch mit einer Widmung von mir. Das wäre perfekt. Würdest du es dann selber mitnehmen, nur damit es nicht in der Kiste liegt, ist die Frage. Boah, aber dann, wenn dich jemand sieht, wie du dein eigenes Buch rausnimmst, das ist ja der gesellschaftliche Tod. Und dann siehst du, dann schaust du an und von hinten sieht man auf dem Hardcover-Deckel dein Bild, wie du lächelst und daneben du in echt, wie du tief traurig dieses Bild anschaust. Und das ist ja letztlich dann wiederum ironischerweise das, worum es bei Schatten in Rom ging. Das war ja genau der gesellschaftliche Unterschied und die Klassenunterschiede, die es auch gerade in Rom natürlich vor diesem Werkjob dieser Kassen... Ja, ja, ich glaube, wir haben es wirklich alle gelesen. Es war ja lange, also es war ja recht gut gegangen, aber... Ja, aber wir sind mehr Leute als gekauft haben. Das ist eine versteckte... Das stimmt. Also ergo, Subtraktion, wir müssen es doch Leute nicht gekauft haben. Ich meine nur, weil du sagst, wir haben alle gelesen, und deswegen unterbrichst du mich immer, wenn ich erzähle, worum es in Schatten in Rom geht.
Wie hoch waren die Verkaufszeiten? Nochmal. Also wir haben neun Milliarden, ich glaube, wo sind wir gerade? Aktueller World Count. Menschen wie viele auf der Welt. Acht Milliarden. Oh, ich habe sieben, 951un fünf eins Milliarden. So, also Rundnummer grob auf acht Milliarden davon. Wie viele Exemplare hast du verkauft? Sechshundert. Sechshundert, okay. Also machen wir acht Komma null drei Milliarden minus sechs hundert. Okay. Und es kann nicht sein, aber es sind immer noch acht Komma,03 Milliarden. Und deswegen meine ich, es gibt noch ein paar mehr Menschen als Exemplare, die verkauft wurden jetzt. Weil du ständig betonst, dass es alle gelesen haben. Ja, ja. Ist Schatten eigentlich da der Plural oder Singular? Wenn du sagst Schatten in Rom, ist es ein Schatten oder mehrere Schatten? Das ist genau diese Ambiguität, über die ich will, dass hier geredet wird.
Ja, aber Ambiguität ist nicht so ein tolles Thema für einen Roman, weil du willst ja wissen, worum es geht.
Wenn man immer sagt, worum geht es und du sagst, naja, um die Ungenauigkeit und die Ambiguität, es geht um ein Wort.
Lest das Buch und dann redet ihr noch darüber.
Naja, es ist ein Erotik-Abenteuer in Rom!
Ja, ein Erotik-Abenteuer.
Kann man doch mal sagen!
Ja, es ist Sexreise.
Na ja, so würde ich es auch nicht sagen. Soise! Naja, so würde ich es auch nicht sagen. So würde ich auch nicht sagen. Also man kann es auch auf den Punkt bringen oder nicht. Im Kolosseum, während der Führung. Das ist eine Szene! Als ob das... Das ist nicht die wichtige Szene! Es soll doch nur den Tabubruch gross machen. 80 Seiten! Von wie vielenig seiten von wie vielen da wo früher die christen gestorben sind unter tiger klauen das ist doch genau ich finde es geschmacklos menschen gestorben der tabubruch weil sie halt aus diesem krassen katholischen elternhaus kommen aber das ist doch kein tabu die die die also tabu ja die chrenverfolgung im alten Rom, das ist kein Tabu im Sinne, oder? Also ich meine, wenn du schon Tabu brichst, dann mach doch ein modernes Tabu. Was ist denn doch ein modernes Tabu? Naja, halt... Was? Naja, halt unsere Konsumkultur. Außerdem will ich nicht mein Buch immer interpretieren müssen. Ja, aber ich verstehe es. Man sollte dem Kind nicht die Fragen stellen, wie ist es denn gemein. Ja, aber es ist halt einfach so ungenau beschrieben oft auch. Aber es ist so vage. Es ist halt gemein, es ist einfach wahnsinnig vage. Das habe ich auch gelesen, jetzt hat ja Frank-Walter Steinmeier unser Bundespräsident. Ja, unser ach so ... Unser ach so toller Bundespräsident. Okay, wir wollen da jetzt gar nicht so äussern. Aber der hat ein Buch rausgebracht, Wir. Und die Idee ist es halt so jetzt so ein bisschen, was ist Deutschland im Kern, Werte, Vereinigung, bla bla bla bla, was sind wir alle, worauf können wir uns gerade alles zumindest mal committen? Das ist so die Aufgabe des Buchs gewesen, aber natürlich aus einer Instanz, da kannst du nicht edgy sein, du kannst nicht Partei ergreifen, du musst ja wirklich alle abholen. Und ich glaube, das ist dann, ich habe es nicht gelesen, aber ein bisschen was darüber gehört. Aber da ist kein Gag drin? Das ist ein kleiner Gag am Ende. Ich glaube, das ist genau das vageste Buch aller Zeiten, weil jede Richtung, die man einschlagen könnte, wird sofort wieder abgeholt. Und das ist fast ein rhetorisches Meisterwerk, finde ich. Und fast wieder dann ein grosser Gag, weil das ist ja eine Nichtsaussage am Ende. Ja, diese Präsidentenposition ist mir eh schon lange im Dorn im Auge, so dieses Repräsentatieren. Aber dann repräsentatier mich doch, dann lass uns doch die Präsidenten-Olympiade machen, so alle Länder bringen ihren Repräsentanten, jetzt nicht den Kanzler, der muss was machen, na, Talent im allgemeinen, der Bundespräsidenten-Song-Contest, genau, so, die singen Song, die machen Quiz, da gibt's ein Wettrennen, Kletterpark, sowas, und dann wirklich sagen, okay, gut, wer hat denn dann den krassesten so. Aber jetzt auch nicht nur sportlich, weil sonst haben wir das Problem, dass dann nur irgendwie so krasse Sportler zum Präsidenten gewählt werden, sondern auch wirklich allgemeinwissen und so. Und dann mal wirklich auch so Debate Club auch. Und jetzt mit der Startnummer 16, Frank-Walter Steinmeier mit, er hat sich Hey Jude von den Beatles ausgesucht. Viel Spaß.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger, liebe Jude, wir sind heute hier zusammengekommen, um die Demokratie zu feiern als ein Fest der Gleichberechtigung und Mitwirkung.
Demokratie heisst Verantwortung übernehmen. Hey Jude, don't let me down, take a sad song and make it better. Oh, er singt wunderschön. Steinwe, alle wogen mit im Publikum. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Bundespräsidenten treten gegeneinander an. Er muss ja auch gegen Monarchen antreten dann wahrscheinlich. Also die ganzen...
Die Monarchen aus dem Mon...
Ja, sag nicht mal Monarch.
Monarch aus dem Monaco.
Monarch.
Gib mir so eine schwarze Liste.
Ich brauche einfach so eine schwarze Liste von Worten, die ich nicht mehr sagen kann,
wo ich ja deine ach so wohlfeilen Ohren nicht mehr bezirzen darf.
Wir brauchen generell mehr schwarze Listen.
Das ist einfach...
Ich mag schwarze Listen. Hast du schwarze Listen in deinem Leben? Ich liebe schwarze Listen. Nee, meinst du jetzt so, was meinst du damit genau? Naja. Leute, die du geblockt hast bei Instagram, sind keine schwarze Listen. Nee, aber einfach so, zum Beispiel, und auf, also ich sag das, du sprichst nochmal aus, jeder übertreibt auf schwarzen Listen. Weil, ich hab zum Beispiel mit einem Callcenter angeschafft. Angeheueschafft und da gab es dann auch eine Liste von wenn die anrufen, direkt abwimmeln. Okay, und dann erwarten die, dass du, ja hallo hier ist der Pascal Brenner. Oh Herr Brenner, ja es ist gerade ganz schlecht, bei uns sind gerade alle Rohre gebrochen, das Büro, ah platsch, platsch,, platsch, tu mir leid, Herr Brenner, ich ruf sie, ich ruf sie, ich ruf sie, ich ruf sie morgen zurück, ich ruf sie morgen zurück, wenn das funktioniert, Herr Bruder, ich ruf sie morgen zurück, ich muss leider ganz kurz weg, ich bin noch da, aber ich muss leider ganz kurz weg, okay, wiederhören, oh, jetzt läuft das Wasser in den Hörer, jetzt läuft das Wasser in den, sowas, ja? Das lernt man dann im Callcenter auch. Meine Frage ist, hast du alle Namen auswendig? So, und dann ist ja die Frage, was steht da drauf? Da stand dann zum Gleisbild drauf, bei unserem Münchner Abzock Callcenter, was man mittlerweile sagen kann. Weil die hochgenommen wurden? Es wurden nämlich ein paar Callcenter letzte Woche hochgenommen. stopp, stopp. Ich möchte dazu nichts sagen. Wurden hochgenommen. Ich möchte dazu nichts sagen. Niemand wurde hoch, niemand war unten und musste hoch, also das Du hast angeschafft und die wurden hochgenommen. Die sind weder oben noch unten noch auf irgendeinem Weg dazwischen. So, das Hopps genommen. Nee, nichts genommen, nichts geholt, Mitte, Mitte. Und da stand dann, ja, und da stand dann Herr Müller, Frau Bruckner, die New York Times. Das fand ich so geil. Wo ich mir dachte, nie im Leben so, und da denke ich mir nicht mehr. Was ist die Geschichte? Hat die New York Times dann mal angerufen, weil die recherchiert haben an einem Peace? Das kann sein, es kann sein, dass die ein Hitpiece geplant haben. Die haben ein Hitpiece geplant. Und die haben noch ein fehlendes Puzzlestück gebraucht. Aber deswegen sage ich auf die schwarze Liste so, wenn du so einen Laden hast zum Beispiel, hier unerwünscht. Nazis. Udo, Frau Lechner und dann der König von Schottland. Einfach so Namen draufstellen, damit du weißt, die New York Times ist ja nicht erwünscht. Allerdings, ist das ein Problem? Ist das wirklich ein Problem? Hast du irgendwo Hausverbot? Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste. Also ich müsste mal in jedes Haus rein, um zu gucken, wo ich tatsächlich bestehen darf. Man hat in den meisten Häusern erstmal Hausverbot. Die meisten, ja, einen Grossteil hast du tatsächlich Hausverbot. Das sind in den meisten Häusern erstmal nichts zu suchen. Nee, überhaupt nichts, gar nichts. Ich glaube, ich auch nicht, aber ich fände es eigentlich ganz schön. Ich war letztens in, also es war ein Gebäude, ich hatte ein bisschen Zeit, totzuschlagen und bin dann durch die Gegend gelaufen und dann stand da so Notare. Und da dachte ich mir, komm, gehst mal rein. Einfach mal so, sich umgucken. Einfach mal so, kann ich Ihnen helfen? Nee, ich gucke nur. Bei rechtlichen Grenzübertritten würde ich nicht bei den Notaren reingehen und anfangen.
Weil das war so ein schönes Treppenhaus, so ein schönes Holztreppenhaus, ein geschwungenes Treppenhaus, war ein relativ enger Raum, aber trotzdem so ein ganz gedrungener, wie so ein Humberto Eco-Kloster-Treppenhaus. Ich wollte es mir einfach angucken und dachte, ich gehe einfach mal rein und dann bin ich da hochgegangen und dann schaue ich so durch die Glastür, die Augen einer Sekretärin treffen meine und die so, und ich. Ah, runter, sorry. Gestikuliert, es wird gestikuliert, runtergezeigt, oh jetzt beide Finger gehübt, Schriftgeste, eine Schreibgeste, macht er, wedet mit den beiden Händen, zeigt runter, macht so Auswechsel, die Fussballer-wechsel gehst. Ja. Und da war ich einfach unterwegs, weil ich es schön fand, aber dachte ich mir auch, das hat sich, glaube ich, am ehesten so angefühlt wie Hausverbot, weil ich hatte da einfach nichts zu suchen, einfach nichts zu suchen. Aber ich mag das. Ich dachte einfach nur, schöner Raum gehe ich rein. Ich mag das ja sehr, ist ein bisschen plakative Erkenntnis jetzt, aber zu wissen, dass du, wenn du Räume betrittst, die eigentlich nicht für deinen Zugang sind, da passieren Dinge. Ja, ja, da sind auch wirklich Leute drin in diesen Häusern, das ist ja nicht selbstverständlich. Ihr gleiches komplexes Leben, mit den gleichen komplexen Gedanken und auch wenn du da nicht reingeguckt hättest, sie hat da gearbeitet und die Male, wo du da nicht reingegangen bist, war sie wahrscheinlich auch schon da und du wusstest gar nicht von ihrer Existenz. Also du lebst ein kleines, kleines Mini-Leben. Drecksrotzleben. Ja, sag's doch mal, wie es ist. Und ich war in einem Kartenladen, einem Laden, wo also so Maps, Karten, nee, also so Landkarten, Landkarten angefertigt werden, mega gut. Angefertigt werden. Ja, ganz interessant. Und ich habe Gespräche belauscht, weil da war dann so ein Laden mit ganz vielen Karten und dann konnten wir so, die Globen waren dann auch gross da. Meine doofe Frage, aber es gibt doch alle Karten. Es gibt alle Karten, ja gut, da ändert sich natürlich auch politisch viel, ne, Klimawandel, Meeresspiegel steigen, sinken, denke ich mir jetzt. Beides. Einfach mal aus. Dann muss man die Landkarte. Dann muss man ja nichts ändern. Dann muss man die Gletscher verschwinden, die muss man ja auch einzeichnen auf eine Landkarte. Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung. Oder rausradieren. Ja, rausradieren. Oder dann so ein Update, so ein Aufkleber, den man dann drüber klebt. Und das machen die in diesem kleinen Laden Hamburg? Das machen die in dem kleinen Laden in Hamburg. Und dann bin ich so in so einen Hinterraum gegangen, wo dann so antike Karten waren.
Was ist denn mit dir los? Und historische Karten waren.
Und warum gehst du denn in die Hinterräume?
Ich war unterwegs, ich habe ein bisschen gelauscht. Und das waren so antike Karten und auch so historische Karten. Also wirklich dann, die haben irgendwie mehrere hundert Euro gekostet, gerade dann so irgendwie Hafenkarten, da wurde viel historisch gemalt, irgendwie vor zweihundert Jahren. Und dann kann man das ja kaufen, gibt es oft auch als Bild, kann man sich aufhängen für diesen nautischen, ruppigen, rauen Werf, den manche Leute sich in die Wohnung holen wollen. Rustikales. Und dann habe ich gesehen, da in der Ecke saß ein offensichtlich sehr intellektueller gebildeter Kartenmensch mit einem alten Mann, der wirklich mit so einem Gehstock da stand. Und er meinte, ja, also sie haben jetzt natürlich schon mein Interesse geweckt, muss ich sagen, nur preislich, müssten wir natürlich nochmal gucken, der Verkäufer so, ja, ja, sicher, natürlich, und das müssen wir uns auch nicht heute entscheiden, es ist nur, das Stück kam gerade heute erst rein, da müssen wir natürlich gucken, wie es mit den Interessenten aussieht. Du Sch Schande, das ist das beste Gespräch der Welt. Und ich dachte mir, ich habe mich nicht mehr bewegt und dann so, ja, also, und dann meinte der alte Mann, da muss ich jetzt schon sagen, dass meine Affektion dann auch steigt und das würde ich dann auch, ja, das würde sich dann auch finanziell niederschlagen. Ja gut, aber wir müssen natürlich jetzt schon verschiedene Interessenten natürlich informieren. Klar, das ist klar. Und du denkst dir, okay, Jesus, worum geht's hier? Und er meinte, können sie denn vielleicht grob schon mal einen Preis nennen? Nee, nicht unbedingt in so einen Rücksprich zu halten. Naja, wie gesagt, das ist jetzt gerade erst reingekommen, das muss natürlich erst mal untersucht werden. Untersucht werden!
Erst mal schauen, wie das aussieht und so.
Also das kann man jetzt schwer sagen.
Ja, aber haben Sie vielleicht einen finanziellen Rahmen, nur vielleicht mal als Einordnung. Dann meinte der Verkäufer, na ja, wenn ich jetzt mal eine Zahl nennen müsste, dann glaube ich, kommen wir hier auf ungefähr 20 Euro. Und ich in meinem Versteck einfach... Was? Können wir aufhören? Die Länge und die Art, wie dieses Gespräch geführt wurde, steht nicht im Verhältnis zum Preis.
Weil ich dachte mir, ich dachte mir, scheiße, mir war nie klar, dass Landkarten so viel wert sind. Holy shit, und dann dachte ich mir, ah ne, meine Meinung war richtig, so, die sind nichts wert. Das Gespräch steht nicht im Verhältnis zum Preis. Überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht. Aber es war fantastisch, weil ich dachte, ich hätte hier so ein Juwel gefunden, wo wirklich irgendwie so, ja, das sind schon acht Millionen. Ja, ich dachte, es ist so eine Uncharted oder Indiana Jones artige Geschichte und es geht um die erste Karte von Columbus. Irgendwie sowas, Schatzkarte. Und dann kriegst du die Columbus-Karte, wo noch eine Insel eingezeichnet wurde, die man bis lange noch nicht gefunden wurde. Genau, und da muss ja was liegen. Und der alte Mann mit dem G-Stock, Nazi, ist offensichtlich der Nazi böse und dann kommt der Indiana Jones und dann geht er durch den Laden und sagt, die Karte, die Karte von Columbus, sie sollte heute hier ankommen. Moment, sie ist da, sie fehlt, wo ist sie? Die Kiste ist leer. Ich habe sie gerade verkauft, sie wurde gerade verkauft. An Gerd Möller. An diesen alten Mann und wir sehen den alten Mann, wie er sprintet über die Strasse, in eine Corvette steigt und wegfährt. In eine Corvette? Keine Ahnung, ich kenne mich nicht aus mit Autos. Da hast du mich verloren, der Film. Aber das ist das Ding, da dachte ich, ich tauche mal ein in so eine mysteriöse Welt, aber nee. Ich finde gut, du hast beide Erfahrungen gemacht. Also zum einen, du gehst Treppen hoch und da sitzt jemand. Du merkst, die Welt ist komplexer, als man denkt. Dann gehst du in diesen Hinterraum von belaustet ins Gespräch, denkst noch mehr, ah, das Leben ist noch komplexer, als man denkt.
Nö, es geht um 20 Euro. Das Leben ist nicht so komplex, wie man denkt. Und deswegen glaube ich, was das Wichtigste für den Menschen ist, die Glasscheibe. Durch eine Glasscheibe Dinge anzuschauen, die eigenen Fantasien und Vorstellungen hinein zu projizieren, aber nicht zuhören. Also diese Frau, die da hinter der Glasscheibe sitzt und denkt, ich hatte ein eigenes Leben und Fantasien, was passiert da in Notarien. In dem Moment, in dem du zuhörst, merkst du, das ist alles trivial, der Quatsch, das ist alles billig, alles nutzlos. Du brauchst die Glasscheibe, um da durchzugucken. Das ist meine Lektion. Also schaut, wundert euch, aber kommt dann doch nicht zu nahe. Sondern bleibt aus einer ironischen, faszinierten Distanz und blickt auf die Dinge mit sicherem Abstand. Den letzten Endes, das Schönste am Kolosseum,
ist ein Schatten. Das ist mein letzter Satz, also du hast es doch gelesen.
Natürlich habe ich es gelesen, Stefan. Oh Mann, das ist schön.
Ich weiss, dass du so ein reiches und brodelndes Innenleben hast. Selbst wenn du einfach nur spontan irgendwas auf den Zettel schreiben würdest, wüsste ich, dass es so vor Kreativität und Inspiration strotzt, dass ich mich daran nicht sattlesen könnte. Ja, das ist das, was jemand immer gesagt hat. Dankeschön. Auch an euch da draußen nochmal, falls ihr ein Geschenk braucht, Muttertag, Vatertag, auch irgendwie Young Adult, ja? Ja, oder ihr wollt einfach nur so richtig schön was Horny lesen, so richtig so ein hottest Erotik. Falls man das Internet ausfällt und man abends alleine ist und vielleicht eine gewisse Wärme spüren möchte in gewissen Körperteilen. Schatten in Rom. Schatten in Rom. Stefan Tietze. Stefan Tietze ist immer noch erste Auflage, wie gesagt, aber lesen wir rein. Hast du noch was in der Garage? Ja, paar noch. Okay. Also in der Garage und in der Storage Unit, die ich mir gemietet habe, die ist teuer, die ist recht teuer. Wie bestellt man es? Also direkt über A-Zone oder kann man auch bei dir dann? Man kann auch direkt bei mir vorbeikommen einfach. Dann signiere ich das und ich kann auch noch Fragen beantworten. Ah, super. Oder halt an so ziemlich jeder Strassenecke in so einer zu verschenken. Glaube ich, findet man es auch, also falls man jetzt nicht sich leisten kann. Wie meinst du das? Ich habe es jetzt schon häufig, also wirklich sehr häufig gesehen an jeder Ecke. Ich habe Argo halt immer gesehen, weil es auch ein guter Film ist und deswegen fühle ich mich in der Gesellschaft eigentlich recht wohl. Nee, das ist ist kein Qualitätsurteil, nur ein Akzeptanzurteil. Stefan, ich wünsche dir ganz viel Erfolg. Ich wünsche dir auch viel Erfolg. Wir schauen mal nächste Woche, wie die Verkaufszahlen aussehen, ob es was bewirkt hat. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du dabei warst. Vielen Dank, dass du in die Räume gehst, in die wir alle nicht gehen. Gerne, gerne. Sei ein bisschen vorsichtig dabei, weil das kann auch gefährlich sein. Vielleicht hörst du Dinge, die du nicht hören darfst. Ich glaube, man muss einmal im Leben auch Hausverbot bekommen haben.
Ich mache jetzt die Bucketlist, ich will einmal Hausverbot.
Habt ihr irgendwo Hausverbot? Schreibt es uns in die Kommentare.
Haut rein, macht's gut, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche.